mintió deliberadamente donald trump al
pueblo de eeuu durante los primeros
meses de la pandemia el mandatario
minimizó públicamente y en repetidas
ocasiones los peligros del cob y 19
me gustaría pediría advertir a los
medios de comunicación ya todos los
demás involucrados que no haga nada para
incitar al pánico porque no hay razón
para entrar en pánico en absoluto pero
según revelan los audios de las
entrevistas realizadas en ese periodo
por el periodista bob woodward para su
nuevo libro reich el mandatario si sabía
de la gravedad del nuevo coronavirus
siempre he querido restarle importancia
es muy complicado
es muy delicado e incluso más mortífero
que la gripe común
un discurso radicalmente opuesto al que
trump transmitía la opinión pública se
irá solo mantengan la calma ante la
nueva polémica y cuando eeuu roza los
190 mil decesos por coronavirus chrome
se ha retractado de sus declaraciones
pasadas alegando que intentaba contener
el pánico y la histeria colectiva bueno
creo que si dijera que para reducir el
pánico tal vez
soy un admirador de este país amo
nuestro país y no quiero que la gente se
asuste desde la oposición su rival en la
carrera por la casa blanca el demócrata
joe biden le acusa de mentir al pueblo
estadounidense y él tenía la información
sabía lo peligroso que era y mientras
esta enfermedad mortal arrasaba nuestra
nación no hizo su trabajo a propósito
fue una traición de vida o muerte para
el pueblo estadounidense no fue hasta
julio que el republicano cambió su
discurso y comenzó a usar mascarillas en
público un giro de 180 grados
incentivado por las encuestas que
muestran que dos tercios de los
estadounidenses desaprueban su gestión
de la pandemia de cara a las elecciones